dentist
gave me Contour sorry questions
Isabelle shares her true initial
feelings about gay being transgender and
it was not all cute and sweet like we
thought it was sentimuches yo
Pence
let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia I hope
you are well I'm so excited because I
have some great things coming up for you
I went to Miami and spent time with
Darcy and Stacy we talked about it all
from their filtered pictures to if their
sisterly competition between them to
Darcy's love life I know boy yeah and I
got an inside look into Stacy's designer
filled closet it was a good time you
gotta do the runway walking I'll do it
what you got yes okay okay
plus I also had a chance to stop by
Lauren and Alex's place to chat with
them and see their adorable kids in
person they are so cute hey hey no
fighting boys shy what are you doing
hey no pushing him
we had the opportunity to see how the
family of five gets ready for the day in
the mornings
[Music]
and once the kids were off to school
Lauren and Alex gave me a tour of their
spot make sure you subscribe to
entertainment tonight's YouTube channel
so you don't miss what we have coming
for you now when it comes to this week's
episode of the other way
I am not even gonna front it was one of
those episodes where it was enjoyable to
watch but after it was over I was
sitting there scratching my head like
what am I gonna talk about there wasn't
any major must-see moments that said we
did learn some new information that'll
be important for the rest of the season
before we get into Isabelle detailing
her first reaction to Gabe being a trans
man I want to talk about Nicole in my
mood we met them for the first time in
this episode my name is Nicole I'm 38
and I live in Los Angeles California
Nicole delivers food and resells clothes
to make ends meet she met Mahmoud who
was 26 during a meditation trip to Egypt
on the last day of my trip I was
shopping for fabric
and I wandered into the fabric store
there's this like this super cute boy
with like these big brown eyes and these
big sexy muscles when the call returned
to the states she and Mahmoud were
talking constantly in a boom he popped
the question
that quick yes couldn't have been more
than five days after I was back in
America where he asked me if if I really
would come to Egypt to marry him and
that she did she returned to Egypt seven
days after he asked her to seven days
love will have you feeling like anything
is possible for real love conquers all
but those love goggles definitely kept
Nicole from seeing the situation clearly
I was in for a rude awakening after they
said I do my moves muslim-based beliefs
took over their marriage he started
giving Nicole rules about how to dress I
love expressing myself through fashion
and how she should interact with other
men how she didn't see this coming
your guess is as good as mine but after
living in Egypt for two months it was
much different than I thought she was
out of there
she left fast forward to now she wants
to try to make it work again so she's
moving back to Egypt and her friend's
response
says it all
right what where I'm going to live with
Mahmoud in Egypt
but I thought you're
separating she said that like it was a
secret the first time I moved within a
week I realized how different it is to
live in Egypt than it is to visit I
don't drive I don't speak the language
it was just really struggling there with
culture shock getting a rose after two
months Mahmoud and I decided to apply
for a spousal Visa so he could come to
the U.S and in the meantime I would go
back and forth thank you
I went back and forth to Egypt about six
times and things started to fall apart I
mean we fought
all the time about everything it got so
bad between these two that after 11
months of marriage Nicole canceled
mahmoud's visa application told him she
wants a divorce and I blocked him
yes she blocked him
[Music]
every time I turned around there was
like a new rule that I didn't know
existed but that I was breaking
how much does he know about your La life
like if he FaceTime him right now right
why would he say he got a beer would he
freak out yes his dress to your friends
drinking with you in public so this is
bad right yeah I feel like you should be
open to like receiving
this you know you just being yourself
I feel the same way and believe me we've
had fight after fight uh about the same
the same thing
one thing I learned recently where I had
to relearn is not to abandon or dim down
the qualities you love about yourself to
make someone else comfortable that's not
love and plain and simple if you can't
be yourself around your partner that
person is not for you you shouldn't have
to force love or lose yourself trying to
keep it I'm not sure why Nicole thinks
it's going to be different when she goes
back to Egypt this time but we'll see
all right let's move on to Isabelle and
Gabe my name is Isabel I'm 34. I'm from
El Carmen Colombia in a day Gabe is set
to move to Colombia to be with Isabel in
this episode sets up her backstory I
mean
she's a single mom raising a 16 year old
daughter Sarah and an 11 year old son
Miguel foreign
relationship with her son's father
Isabelle didn't think she was ever going
to be in a relationship again and quite
frankly she didn't want to but then came
Gabe if
[Music]
laughs
Gusto mucho
Alegria is
cantando Bailando
they say love comes when you're not
looking but no one ever tells you how to
not look for it sometimes I go out and
I'm like don't look today don't look
how do you not look for something you
want at this point I'm assuming you just
stay focused on you focused on dating
yourself focused on working toward your
goals and with time you'll become so
content with the life that you've built
that naturally you won't look sometimes
you have to loosen your grip to allow
things to fall into place but I remind
myself don't fall into the tribe of
loosening your grip solely because you
want to partner loosen your grip because
you want to discover that you who truly
doesn't need anyone else to make them
happy after all whether we know it or
not that's the Fulfillment we are really
seeking right now that's on paper
all right enough of my TED talk during
an outing with her daughter who is
stunning by the way Isabel and her
daughter are both beautiful they look
like sisters or friends and look they
both did the fan thing at the same time
[Music]
anyway during their outing Isabel opens
up about the moment she found out Gabe
was transgender and this was before he
came out and told her
and this
gave me Contour sorry
this picture that you see here this was
like probably one month on testosterone
and then the last picture is me
currently today is my one two three four
five six seven eight years on
testosterone so Gabe had been
documenting his transition on Instagram
and that's how Isabelle found out which
took me by surprise because the way it
was explained in the premiere was that
Gabe was upfront with her about his
status but in all actuality social media
revealed his truth in his text
confirming it follows
nombre
[Music]
yo
muchas preguntas
I
Noe Noe Nino
Perfection
Isabella admits that the truth scared
her at first yo
trans
istors Linda
queries
well she did say her and her daughter
are great friends and while Sarah was
also shocked at first she's fully
supportive of Isabelle and Gabe's love
as long as her mom's happy she's happy
yeah
now there are three important people who
are close to Isabel who are still
unaware of Gabe's Journey the first one
is Isabelle's son Miguel she and Sarah
aren't sure if an 11 year old is ready
for a conversation about gender identity
the other two Isabel's parents
apparently her dad is super conservative
[Music]
is
Amelia
um
[Music]
foreign
yeah well keep it on your radar when
Gabe and Isabelle decide to tell her
parents it's definitely going to be a
big deal all right well next week it
looks like we are finally going to meet
Debbie
[Music]
I found the right person that suits my
personality I'm 67 years old I'm moving
to Morocco to marry Osama he's 24 years
old but I love them
how do you know he's not scamming you oh
he's definitely scamming her look I'm
old let me have my fun you may be in
love but this guy's young he has nothing
to lose you have everything to lose by
this the last thing I want to see is my
mom get hurt again I always feel for the
kids who have to step into parent mode
on this show look at Debbie with the van
something else all right 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with E.T because we
are covering it all I will see you next
time
foreign